the woman at the center of the Bill
Cosby sexual assault trial returns to
court today to give more testimony
andrea constand yesterday said she
trusted the actor-comedian
she says the alleged assault made her
feel humiliated and confused Cosby
denies the charges his defense team
questioned konstanz credibility in her
decision to stay in touch with him after
the alleged assault
Jericka Duncan is at the courthouse in
Norristown Pennsylvania where
cross-examination continues this morning
drink oh good morning good morning
although more than 50 women have accused
Bill Cosby of sexual assault it's
constant allegations that brought Cosby
to this trial the 79 year old yesterday
watched this constant testified for a
little more than three hours at times he
appeared to be frowning and even shaking
his head speaking publicly for the first
time tuesday andrea constand told the
jury in detail how bill cosby a man she
saw as her mentor allegedly drugged and
violated her constant testified that
cosby gave her three blue pills to help
her relax during a 2004 visit to his
pennsylvania home about 20 minutes after
taking the pills she said she started
slurring her words had trouble with her
vision and told him quote I see two of
you the 44 year old cried as she
explained how Cosby then sexually
assaulted her Constance said her body
was limp and she couldn't fight him off
months after the alleged encounter Cosby
left four tickets for constant and her
family to attend his show in Canada she
testified she didn't have the courage to
tell her family what happened but that
it was a burden
Cosby's defense team attempted to
discredit constan story they pressed her
on why she called Cosby more than 50
times after the alleged assault the
defense also brought up an inconsistent
statement she gave to Canadian police
constant told investigators she had
known Cosby six months at the time of
the alleged incident but actually knew
him for a year and a half
Victoria Valentino is one of several
Cosby accusers attending the trial when
Andrea was describing all of the sexual
contact the incident you could see him
he was sitting there and he was like
rubbing his hand over his head and
looking down and I think she had him
rattled constan claims that Cosby made
inappropriate advances at her twice
before the alleged 2004 sexual assault
the defense team asked her why did she
continue to see him after those
allegations that he made those two
advances she said she trusted Cosby and
didn't think he would take things
further
Gail all right thank you very much
Jericho